we're going to begin this hour with
troubling signs that the omicron variant
may hit the u.s harder than many of us
had hoped the number of reported daily
cases topped 800 000 on one day last
week yikes now that does not include
those who tested positive with the at
home test or have mild symptoms and
never got tested at all so this is
leading some experts to tell the federal
government that we need a new strategy
to fight this pandemic one of those
experts is epidemiologist dr celine
gander we love when she's here she joins
us at the table good to see you dr
gallander because you and two other very
prominent doctors zeke emanuel and
michael ulsterholm have sent a letter in
jama and you're saying listen we need to
have a new normal
and a new normal with covid19 does not
include the eradication or elimination
we've got to figure out a way to to live
with this so what exactly do you mean
because the biden administration is
saying listen
we're going to beat this we will beat
this i think we're all waiting for that
tada moment it's over that's not
happening you say
gayle i think we would all love to jump
in a time machine that would take us
back to november 2019. i think for some
people that means i just want to forget
about covet i want to go about my normal
life for some people it means let's
eradicate or eliminate covid so we don't
have to worry about it anymore and
unfortunately if your goal is to save
lives to prevent hospitalizations we're
going to have to have another strategy
we can't go back in a time machine but
we can take action so where do you put
the what number of daily cases or daily
hospitalizations or daily deaths are we
then comfortable with as a country to
move into this new normal and say okay
it's behind us mostly the emergency is
over yeah tony what we're using as a
starting point for discussion and people
might disagree and think about you know
that's too strict or that's not strict
enough but what we're using as a
starting point for discussion is what
did really bad years of flu and rsv and
other viral respiratory disease look
like pre-pandemic and using that sort of
as a benchmark for starting the
conversation i think some places will
want to really suppress cases even more
than that but some places might want to
be more liberal but that's a starting
place yeah some people say just stop
being afraid and just go back to work
and you're saying that's not at all what
you mean yeah i think i'm so tired of
being tired and being afraid of this i
am trying to navigate myself what can we
do what should we not do right and i
think the expression learn to live with
covid can be problematic because i think
it's really about saying to people stop
being scared get back to work that's not
what you're saying yeah what we're
saying is we're going to have to
co-exist with covid and how do we do
that safely where people are not ending
up in the hospital where our hospital
system is not buckling under the weight
of all of those coveted cases as it is
now can you can you help us understand
what's going on with kids right now
because we keep hearing about a big
increase in the number of kids
hospitalized and the total percentage of
kids hospitalized but at the same time
we're hearing that if you dig into the
numbers some of those kids are coming in
with a broken hand but they also test
positive so they're not there for coving
right so when we're kind of figuring out
risk and how bad things are how do we
deal with that
so we're seeing so much covid in the
community everybody who comes in the
hospital gets tested because we need to
sort out who needs to be in a covered
room versus a regular room so
everybody's getting a test and just
because there's so much of it out there
in the community you're going to have
some people who come in you know a kid
with a broken arm who just happens to
have copid and it is a challenge right
now they're you know i've just been on
service at bellevue the last two weeks
some of our patients and maybe i have a
patient who came in with heart failure
covet tipped them over the edge but they
don't really have a bad case of covid do
you say that's with or from you know
there's this whole gray zone in between
it makes it hard to know how worried you
should be then when you hear these
numbers
it is it is and this is something that
you know epidemiologists statisticians
are really trying to dig into to figure
out how much of this is truly omicron
causing bad lung disease versus you just
happen to have it dr gander so we got
vaccinated boosted so we can have
optimal protection right um and i want
to speak from the perspective of some
friends and family maybe even some
viewers that are sitting at home saying
okay well i know people that are
vaccinated i know people that are
boosted that are still getting coveted
um so why should i go out there and get
vaccinated and boost it because we still
have a large population of individuals
that are hesitant what would you say to
them that's right uh we have over a
third of americans who are still not
vaccinated and that is a real challenge
to getting back to a more close to
semblance of normal what i would say is
that yes we are seeing breakthrough
infections even in people who are
boosted but they're like the common cold
they're not landing you in the hospital
these are not people who are having to
put on a ventilator it's less severe
that doesn't work
that definition of mild though does seem
to be a slippery slope because i've
heard some people who who you guys say
are mild they're not in the hospital but
they're really really in a lot of
trouble and very and it's very painful
for them
the way we as doctors define what is
mild versus severe is really a question
of do you need oxygen do we need to put
you on supplemental oxygen have your
oxygen levels dropped without it that's
how we define it so you might feel awful
but you're not requiring that extra
oxygen so when you say we need to learn
to live with it i'm still trying to
figure out exactly what we have to do
should we go is it okay to go to a
restaurant is it okay to go to a place
is it okay to go to a sporting event is
it okay to travel what does that mean so
the key interventions that we outline in
the jama pieces are in addition to
vaccination masking so really upping
your mass game to
either a can 95 or an n95 mask
improving indoor ventilation and air
filtration and then using testing to
figure out who's contagious who's not
who needs treatment so for example you
mentioned the broadway theater that's a
place where you can wear a mask where
they can improve their indoor air error
ventilation air filtration and they do
ask you at the door are you vaccinated
so there's layers of protection there
you're okay with the at-home test
because there was some question about
that are you okay with that home desk so
there was a in fact two colleagues of
mine one who works with the sports
leagues robbie sika and blithe adamson
who works with the broadway theaters
collaborated on a study looking at this
and what we're seeing is that the rapid
tests do work
they pick up omicron probably about two
days later than a pcr test would if
you're testing every day you see that
but they do work
all right dr celine gander i know this
won't be your last time at the table but
so glad you're here i'm glad you're here
today
if you have any questions about the
coronavirus pandemic share them with us
and our medical team we'll try to answer
them for you and you can send your
questions to our cbs morning's facebook
twitter and instagram pages or you can
email us too lots of ways to get in
touch coronavirus viacomcbs.com